Speaker 1: I want to talk to you today about
comedy and sheltered people and completely screwed
up senses of humor. One of the most interesting
psychological and cultural phenomena that we can
look at right now is what right wingers think
is funny. Now, we've talked about before how
when right wingers have tried to do satirical
news, it just like doesn't work. And part of
it is you can't really tell the difference from
actual right wing news because it's also dumb and
stupid. And shows like the half hour news hour on
Fox News failed. You know, you've got this guy,
Greg GUTFELD on Fox News, who I guess is a
comedian. You can't tell when he's doing a comedy
bit and when he's being serious. Right wing comedy
just it doesn't really work in a normal way.
I am now going to present to you sort of
the latest edition of What the Hell Are
These People Thinking? I bring you today a
clip from this Reawaken America tour. These
are these events that are held in sort of like
circus tents that are kind of like churches all
over the place. Many of these are affiliated with
Christian hate preacher Greg Locke. They brought
in comedian Jim Breuer. Jim Breuer is now, I
guess you can call him a right wing comedian.
And what is amazing to me is he mocks flu shots.
He mocks vaccines. He seems to mock Damar Hamlin,
the NFL player who recently suffered a cardiac
arrest on the field and thankfully is moving
ahead in his recovery. And the crowd just
loves it. This is comedy to these people,
and it is extraordinarily sad in terms of what
it says about our country. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I still have my in-laws, my in-laws
and like we got to get our flu shot and a booster.
Speaker 1: Then another booster. This guy's
clapping. This guy is he's in stitches,
folks. If you're listening, there's
a Vietnam veteran hat wearing guy.
Who is just clapping. He's he's he's so
he's he's almost apoplectic in laughter.
Speaker 2: And so, you know, people starting
to die. Where'd you hear that? Right.
Where do you want those conspiracy theories?
Speaker 1: Whoa. The left had better be ready
for this because the right is starting to get good
at comedy. Look at these young ladies who are just
overcome with laughter.
Speaker 2:
What are you, a cult member?
Extremist one of them.
Speaker 1:
I guess this is an imitation of a left winger
that Jim Breuer is doing. I don't know.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Here in the NFL.
Speaker 1:
So I guess the joke, he falls down, Jim Brewer
throws himself down on the ground like like a
tantrum ing two year old. I guess the joke is,
oh, everything's fine with the vaccines. Oh,
woops. DeMar Hamlin is now down on the
ground. I think the joke is that the
vaccine caused what happened to DeMar Hamlin, of
course, for which there is no evidence. Again,
I'm trying to interpret stuff that is
unintelligible. I believe that's the joke
to the extent that it's a joke that Jim Breuer is
making and that really gets the crowd riled up.
Isn't this great, guys?
Speaker 2:
Crazy conspiracy theorist.
Speaker 1: All right, so then the same,
then the same bit just starts over again. Only the
most sheltered people would find this stuff funny
if. You are if you if your entertainment and
your thinking is mostly watching paint dry.
Maybe this is funny because brewers making, you
know, like a silly face, but it's disturbing
and it's pathetic and it's really disheartening to
see what is considered funny these days. Among the
right and these trends. We mock vaccines and we
mock people who get them and we mock doctors. And,
you know, the last time we talked about Jim
Brewer about a year ago, he was making fun
of people who listen to doctors. But even Brewer
himself, when his wife was was very sick. I forget
what with they think it was a type of cancer.
He wasn't mocking doctors that are specialists
or any of it. He found the best people and he
went to them and he listened to them so that he
could actually get treatment. So even Brewer this
may even be an act as far as Brewer is concerned,
but it reveals this deep ignorance, this deep lack
of empathy towards struggles that people have,
towards people affected by the pandemic, people,
health care workers and on and on and on.
But it's also a reflection of a
larger problem within the right wing
and this increased tendency to retreat into their
echo chambers because this is now no longer even
just, well, different news sources and different
underlying beliefs about ABCD issue. This this
is about we are going to surround ourselves
with people so delusionally like minded that
it becomes an impossibility to ever break out
of this. Right. If you're laughing this hard,
as hard as this woman is laughing at the fact that
Jim Breuer is doing I don't know how you ever get
out of that echo chamber and I don't know how how
our society can actually move forward in any kind
of constructive manner. And I hate that I have
become so cynical and negative about this, but.
I am very I am very pessimistic about it. I mean,
when you see this laughter at what I just played
for you. I don't know where we go from here.
Let me know what you think in the comments.